what is this uh this is some cats in the
wild uh someone saw theo on the train
i'm like oh [ __ ] that looks like
just snacking stamp that's so good
snackies
snacky
where was i going huh probably somewhere
that i'd written down earlier in the day
in a plan
yeah you're even looking at your watch
it looks like yeah busy
what is she snacking on there that ain't
a woman you
[ __ ] yeah it is yeah
actually she has that starting pitcher
for the reds
for the marlborough reds that lady
[Laughter]
if that's a lady that i'm a lady yeah
so i've been trying to tell you this
whole time bro that's me
where was i going probably chasing that
honey over there in a white shirt
yeah that little lady with that lean
head bruh
a lot of lean-headed women out there
a little skinny hat there huh a lot of
lean-headed women right there
that looks like me right now yeah oh now
or i mean whenever but you definitely
look like me now
wow and then we've got uh chappelle
uh useless in the wild
he was a little bit in his feelings
i'm always in my feelings yeah i respect
it yeah have you met this guy
his feelings are great there you go get
that shirt
your feelings are great yeah it is now
oh feelings are great dude you could be
a colonel in the antifa military dude if
you got a feelings or great shirt
oh she's pretty far
[Music]
little brother
delilah i can promise you that by the
[Music]
time
cause he's in secret dude he's in an
adoption home
he's have to be secret yeah it wasn't
bad though was it it wasn't
it wasn't and here you are now
bill see that's when you were that's
when that's when yeah that's what i was
on uh you know
uh what did they call it you were
looking for us whatever it was before
the backflip
do you like them who is that do i like
playing white no i don't like that band
nobody would have guessed that no i
don't like that that's a little too
emotional for me well two emo little to
emo
yeah i was never part of the emo phase
what
yeah were you but there's but we don't
have
tons of proof that i was or was it
everything you talk you're a freaking
living hallmark card aisle
you are the emo face dude
who who who's the king of em like emo
raps big right who's the king of emo rap
kitty cuddies yeah
kid cuddy would be emo maybe a little
backpack rappers yeah they get all sad
and
start rapping yeah cuddy's got some
pretty sad songs honestly we may have
done this on the show or i just saw it
on social media a couple of times but uh
theo
and brendan were in a movie a while ago
that no one ever talks about for some
reason
this is from just watch this
tremors great movie jamie kennedy's in
there amy
no that's a great dune he was in dune
oh that does look like they look like
much better
hollywood versions of us who's that on
the right
what's his name handsome i don't know
his name it is
clive owen no no no no he's older this
guy's real oh
tremors are great movie says fred ward
or freddie ward huh there's a cr there's
a i think he's korean don't get mad at
me i think
there's a korean guy in that movie too
and tremors he dies yeah oh the kid
right
nope nope he's the old man all the old
old dudes yeah
he's japanese is he japanese is he
japanese i thought he's korean he's also
in uh big trouble a little china victor
wong so that's chinese
dude i'm just pissed you guys brought
these donuts man you don't like them
i didn't want to eat today i come in i
figured everybody got up early i'd be
nice and bring people donuts and you
come in like a
[ __ ] why don't you bring people a
salad why don't you bring people
something good for them a little bit of
steroids bruh
bring that intake of d-ball for
everybody come that winter straw just
little ass shots dude one time i was
partying somewhere
i think in new york or something a buddy
of mine uh
he's like hey man i'm going to get some
drugs right they're probably like
1am or 2 a.m and
i was like ah all right man whatever
he's like come with me i was like nah
man i'm chilling man i'm going to sleep
man it was pretty late yeah i'm not
believing this
you're not no you probably got the drugs
well here's what happened
i would have i said wake me up when you
get back with the drugs smart you know
what i'm saying respect
you got a plan yeah dude thank you bro
yeah had a little bit of a plan right
um so the guy comes back he is freaking
steroid to the drugs he bought
it's 4 30 in the morning he's trying to
party
he had a plan to get in shape bro well
look but i'm like dude it takes two
weeks for those to kick
in whatever and he just shot him up
right there into his butt
and did he get swole huh i don't know i
went back to sleep but i saw him
oh i do one of his eyes turned a
different color
you got that bootleg new york he got
that bootleg [ __ ] not the [ __ ] a rod was
taking
dude i i bought some bootleg stuff off
of a dude one time
and it was bootleg steroids oh yeah
real regional type stuff know i feel
like it'd be easy to boot like steroids
yeah because you could just put olive
oil into a thing yeah then just blame it
on you got shitty genetics yeah
it's not my fault it's not working yeah
yeah look at your dad's wrists
look at your
yeah here's another couple ounces man
it's extra-virgin
[Music]
is